hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to never have cavities again
if you're a dentist if you're a parent
make note the derivation of cavities
comes from the Latin word which means
decay and it's just bizarre to me to
think that a small child or even a
teenager that young would have a part of
their body in a state of decay so is it
that they're not brushing enough or
flossing enough or maybe it's not enough
fluoride right
I don't think so this is what's really
happening if you think about the enamel
around the tooth it's stronger than
steel it would take something very very
powerful to disrupt that so it's really
happening to the enamel which is bone
tissue is we're getting a deep
mineralization which we're leaching out
calcium and phosphorus and the way
that's happening is because the pH in
the mouth is becoming very very acidic
the normal pH of your mouth should be
around 7 that's neutral it drops down to
a 6 and a 5 and sometimes even a 4 so
acids have the capacity to break down
bone tissue but if we go earlier there's
an excessive amount of a certain
bacteria that's doing it streptococcus
mutans
and lactobacillus so these two bacterias
are fed you got it sugar okay so when
you consume too much sugar you get too
much bacteria you get an acid pH and it
starts dissolving the teeth so the kids
nowadays consume so much sugar even
liquid candy in the form of soda and I
was that kid I consumed so much candy in
fact every single tooth in my mouth had
a cavity so what you want to do is you
want to start getting your kids on
alternative sugars like xylitol you want
to make desserts and cookies and treats
out of alternative sugars you don't want
to use actual sugar so I put a link down
below of a lot of great ideas for things
that you can make to get these kids off
sugar because it's so easy to prevent
the situation so we don't necessarily
want to deprive the child we want to
replace what they're eating with an
alternative sugar like xylitol or we
throttle or stevia
click the link below and start making
these recipes thanks for watching
hi guys listen I want to thank you so
much for your wonderful comments and I
want to ask you if you wouldn't mind
giving me your review on Google I put a
link down below I'd really appreciate it
and thank you in advance